tom cruise is one of the first producers
to shut a movie down with a pandemic hit
he was also one of the first to figure
out how to resume shooting
and get people back to work he has taken
coven 19 seriously
since day one and that passion just
boiled over
in a big way we are not setting this
movie down is it understood if i see it
again you're
going and so are you that's it
am i clear do you understand what i want
tom yells and swears at his mi7 crew for
two and a half minutes
in leaked audio obtained by the sun
newspaper you
understand the responsibility that you
have
it's the kind of raw passion tom's
delivered on the big screen
i want the truth you can't handle the
truth
it is an up at dawn dried swallowing
siege i will rain down on a godly
firestorm upon you
i am talking scorched earth so what made
tom
so mad in real life well apparently cruz
who is also a producer on the film
became enraged when two crew members
here at this studio outside london
were standing next to each other at a
computer a violation of a rule requiring
people to be six feet apart
i don't ever want to see it again ever
and if you don't do it you're fired and
i see you do it again you're
gone what is the significance of tom
cruise
being so upset about this tom cruise is
feeling the weight
of the movie world on his shoulders
right now you're back here in hollywood
making movies right now
meanwhile george clooney on howard stern
today weighed in on tom's rant
he didn't overreact because it is a
problem and you know i have a friend
who's an ad on another tv show who
just had the almost exact same thing
happen i wouldn't have done it that big
you're in a position of power and it's
tricky right you you do have a
responsibility for everybody else and
he's absolutely right about that and if
the production goes down a lot of people
lose their jobs
by the way mission impossible 7 is
scheduled to be released in november